[Música]
[Aplausos]
en esa alegría mi hermana menor un poco
más grande que lo que está en esas fotos
cuando tenía 17 años me entró un día mi
cuarto y me dijo todo alborotada con sus
duros y me dice ya engaña yo estaba
haciendo deberes
y estaba contenta de mis deberes no tocó
la puerta y había estaba molesta por eso
cuando le veo y tenía unos zapatos que
le quedaban como payaso
y le veo y eran mis zapatos de fútbol
mis zapatos nuevos de fútbol yo acababa
de entrar a la selección del colegio
tenía 11 años
y esos eran mis zapatos y yo estaba
pendientes le digo alegría sal de mi
cuarto y deja los zapatos ella me dice
pero engaña y yo que está al gas de mi
cuarto bueno salió de mi cuarto y se fue
llorando al suyo cerró su puerta no ha
pasado ni medio segundo hasta que entró
mi mami furiosa atrás no te das cuenta
fernanda no te das cuenta que tu hermana
ha pasado toda la tarde tratando de
aprender a hacer cascaritas como tú
quiere jugar fútbol solamente porque tú
juegas fútbol no te das cuenta que tu
hermana el día de ayer me pidió que le
vaya a comprar la misma ropa que tú te
pones
bueno eso me marcó bastante ya sin
embargo no me di cuenta la magnitud de
este evento es todos los años después
esta es mi familia yo vengo de una
familia en la que siempre nos hemos
apoyado siempre queremos como hija has
querido algo mis papás han estado detrás
pendientes apoyándonos siempre
somos tres mujeres mis hermanos y yo las
mismas somos cuatro en la familia
entonces nunca hemos tenido un problema
de decir nunca hemos escuchado en
nuestro crecimiento el hecho de que la
mujer no puede llegar a hacer algo
es más mi papá siempre nos ha dicho que
si nosotros queremos algo y nosotros
proponemos algo siempre vamos a llegar a
obtenerlo
él también cree que lo puede llegar a
hacer este es marcelo man y el una de
las cosas que dice es que está resentido
con la industria del cine porque han
hecho películas a todos los superiores
- hay entonces este es el siguiente el
siguiente objetivo bueno hemos tenido
una familia en la que siempre nos hemos
apoyado con todo eso a mis 16 años yo
decidí que por qué no cambiar el mundo
entonces salí y dije voy a cambiar el
mundo y había algo que a mi familia ya
mis amigos nos molestaba y es el hecho
de que una vez tengo un tráfico y llega
a unas personas por al lado y se cola
entonces decidí que eso era lo que
quería cambiar todos los días iba y me
demoraba 30 40 minutos
tocando la ventana de cada una de las
personas que se colaba diciéndole señor
por favor no se cole porque todos
estamos haciendo la fila pasó una semana
pasaron dos semanas pasó un mes estarán
dos meses y no ningún cambio
entonces yo regresé a mi casa su
percepción nada era una mentira esto que
nos habían dicho que uno puede cambiar
el mundo
nosotros somos tan chiquitos para
cambiar el mundo tiene que haber un
meteorito para cambiar el mundo tienen
que tiene que ser una persona famosa que
tenga millones de seguidores o tiene que
ser un genio que con sus inventos cambia
el mundo y fue ahí cuando me acordé este
evento de la alegría entrando con mis
zapatos de fútbol me di cuenta que si
soy importante me di cuenta que para la
alegría estoy importante me di cuenta
que en su mundo yo tengo el poder de
influenciar
recordé las miles de veces en las que la
les acercó a mí muchas veces poniendo
además atención a mí para tomar
decisiones que hasta mis padres
entonces decidí
que voy a afianzar esta relación y me di
cuenta que este este es el cambio que yo
puedo hacer en el mundo
ahora cuando sólo las dos
estamos en la selección del ecuador
y a través de estos años
en un inicio yo siendo cinco años mayor
yo le enseñaba la ley pero a medida que
nos seguía manejando la relación
aprendemos las dos cada uno de nosotros
de nosotros de nuestra relación y de lo
que hacemos día a día sin embargo ella
lo que es algo mucho más importante y
mucho más poderoso y es que cada una de
nuestras acciones genera un eco que
tiene el potencial de cambiar una
persona incluso a miles de kilómetros de
distancia es un poco difícil de creer
pero yo les va a decir cómo y es que
estábamos en eeuu con mi familia cuando
estábamos perdidos que llegamos al peaje
y mi papi se bajó de mí para ver la tele
pagar le dijo la señorita si es que le
puede enseñar cómo llegar ella trató de
explicarnos no entendíamos por dónde en
el mapa podíamos llegar
entonces las señoritas debajo de la
cabina y se puso al frente del carro le
hizo señas a mí para que se va
ya veo el mapa en el capazo
para con nosotros llegamos no había
ningún carro atrás nuestro para cuando
abrió el mapa en el capot habrían unos
diez carros atrás nuestro para cuando
terminó de explicar le habían no
podíamos contar pero había un yo calculo
unos cuarenta carros otros nuestro
y lo que nos ha impresionado las
instrucciones pero lo que nos impresionó
fue que
ningún carro nosotros estábamos
acostumbrados a que incluso baja la
velocidad y te pican para un parar y
causar un tráfico gigantesco en una
autopista pero nadie nos pitó entonces
ese día mi parte dijo esta es la última
vez que yo y está a menos que sea
por un posible accidente y en realidad
es fácil esta fue la última vez que papi
tal vez estas personas que estaban atrás
en el carro en los carros de atrás en la
fila no se dieron cuenta y tal vez ni
siquiera se acuerdan de este momento
pero con esta acción hizo un cambio en
nuestras vidas un cambio en la forma en
la que nosotros nos comportamos dentro
del tráfico y les digo llevamos ya 20
años desde este día en el que como
familia tratamos de hacer una campaña
personal para concientizar a las
personas de que dejen de gritar quien
sabe y durante estos 20 años hemos
llegado también a otras personas están
haciendo lo mismo es una idea muy
pequeña es una idea que pasa día a día
en cada cosa que nosotros hacemos
todos aprendemos nosotros como seres
humanos generamos alrededor de 60 mil
pensamientos al día y estos pensamientos
vienen de información que nosotros
recibimos a través de nuestros sentidos
de lo que vemos de lo que escuchamos de
lo que sentimos
yo les digo con ustedes todas las cosas
que hacen durante su día a veces no nos
damos cuenta quien nomás está escuchando
quién nomás está bien
pero si les digo una cosa cada persona
que les vio aún cuando no hayan hablado
con ustedes
se quedó grabado en este pensamiento en
alguna parte de su cerebro algunos de
esos pensamientos causan impacto como
fue en esta ocasión
y se quedan grabados para toda la vida
en mi cerebro de la otra persona
y algunas veces este pensamiento llega
también a otras personas a través de la
persona a la que flexiones primero
entonces
realmente si tenemos el poder para
influenciar al resto incluso a miles de
kilómetros de distancia
tenemos un poder que es enorme
pero también tenemos un poder que puede
ser utilizado para bien o para mal
dentro del fútbol femenino yo vivo
muchas veces ese poder a veces no de
forma positiva porque en la era en la
que estamos
las redes sociales da un poder a cada
una de las personas que estamos aquí nos
da el poder de expresarnos y de que
nuestro mensaje llega al otro lado del
mundo en cuestión de segundos y que
escuchamos todo el tiempo pateas como
hombre y
la nena corre como niña la princesa
no puedes porque eres mujer eres muy
femenina para jugar
entonces que tenemos a las mujeres
hombres para jugar
cuando yo empecé con años
muchas personas necesitan
no te metas en una industria en la que
una mujer nunca va a tener un espacio
pero no te metas en el fútbol femenino
que nadie quiere ver todo el femenino
me decían
porque te queremos a cualquier otra cosa
pero no es
y justo a los dos meses de que yo empecé
con niñas
un hombre al otro lado del mundo en
españa' dijo esto
públicamente en televisión los hombres
somos inútiles para la cocina y nosotras
no jugáis fútbol él es juanma ortiz es
bueno más conocido como bear tim godwin
un famoso que tiene el poder de
influencia y que tal vez no sabía pero
que al otro lado del mundo
habíamos muchas mujeres que el fútbol es
nuestra vida
que el fútbol es lo que estamos
dispuestos a dejar todo por hacerlo
y yo les invito al día a que se pongan a
pensar en cada una de sus acciones en
cada cosa que dicen en las redes
sociales en cada cosa que dice en un
estado cada vez que nosotros estamos en
un estadio en un evento público donde
hay una masa de personas nosotros
tenemos el poder de crear una ola
y una ola que llega alrededor del
estadio luego que se suben redes
sociales y que llega al otro lado del
mundo
decidir comenzar con esto el día que
llegó una niña y me dijo nosotros en
años tenemos unas escuelas estamos en un
campamento de verano llegó una niña y me
diste efe ayer estaba con mi papi
en un partido del trabajo de una barrial
y cuando el partido un tiro libre le
silbaron entonces dice porque le silban
y yo le dije de ley porque partió mal y
ahí me doy cuenta
en toda la lucha que yo he tenido y en
todo lo que yo creo que las mujeres
podemos para terminar hoy está
impregnada con este pensamiento de que
las mujeres nunca vamos a poder patear
igual que un hombre o que hay patear
como niña es patear de emilio mal y esto
es lo que ha hecho
ciertos pensamientos que están generada
a través de palabras y acciones de
ciertas personas entonces
yo les invito hoy día que primero nos
demos cuenta que somos importantes
y segundo nos demos cuenta que cada una
estas acciones puede llegar a otra
persona afectarle en una manera en la
que tal vez ese es el pensamiento por
toda su vida
recién en la selección del ecuador
estábamos en el microciclo y una chica
llegó y nos dijo no estaba contando que
ella estaba en él
en su clase y llegó con su permiso de la
selección para poder faltar unos días a
clases y la toque de vaso clase sus
compañeros sabían que ella estaba
seleccionada los compañeros estaban
felicitando y lección que bien
felicitaciones qué orgullo hacerte amigo
cuando llegó el profesor esta supuesta
jugada y le dijo
necesito permiso para poder faltar a
clases el profesor le dijo a tanto
alboroto pensé que era algo más grande
que sólo el fútbol femenino ella dijo
guau me sentí tan pequeña sentí yo he
luchado toda mi vida por llegar a la
selección del ecuador y sentí que
ya no era nada o sea sentí que todo eso
no significaba nada finalmente
y os quiero decir que yo no creo en eso
que creo que nosotros si podemos cambiar
el pensamiento cuando yo empezaba el
fútbol la razón por la que no me
aceptaron en el colegio porque nuestra
vida está tierra yo soñaba con llegar a
la selección del ecuador
pero no me aceptará en la selección de
mi colegio porque no sabía patear un
balón
luche todos los días me queda entrenar
y el último partido que jugué pasa esto
eso cambiará la trayectoria de la pelota
pero fue muy débil
[Aplausos]
pero pierdo abrazo
ah
[Aplausos]
las mujeres seamos orgullosa decir yo
pactado como niña porque si pateamos
como niñas pero también lo podemos hacer
bien
cuando empecé les había comentado que me
dijeron nunca te metas en sol femenino
porque nadie lo quiere ver
y esto es lo que pasó en el último
partido a quien quitó cuando vamos de
locales
[Risas]
a
ah
la gente si quiere ver el fútbol
femenino pero si yo hubiera me hubiera
quedado con lo que me decían las
personas probablemente nunca hubiera
empezado a coña años probablemente no el
que hubiera asistido a mi segunda clase
de fútbol en el colegio
pensemos en la forma en la que hemos
sido influenciadas por el resto y
pensemos como eso nos ha llevado a
pensar de cierta manera
tenemos tenemos el poder del mundo en
nuestras manos tenemos el poder de
generar este pensamiento alrededor del
mundo cada una de nuestras acciones
genera un eco que tiene el potencial de
cambiar a una persona desconocida
incluso a miles de kilómetros de
distancia pensemos en lo que vamos a
hacer con este poder y yo les digo una
una cosa una propiedad de la propiedad
fundamental del eco es que siempre
regresa a su misión muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]